mais marley à genoux des sorties quand
tu m'as manqué oui c'est bon de te
revoir à l'est je dois passer chez
allison quel âge elle a 14 ans et tous
pour toi m il fonctionne à l'eau salubre
il a 20 ans je veux ma part des 10
millions de dollars qui allait changer
notre vie il ya plus de cash sa fille
est devenue très mignonne en grandissant
son ancien coéquipier enlevé d'affilée
la retient dans un taxi ne fout pas de
ma gueule
je veux lui parler tout de suite du tout
dépend de toi pour sauver sa fille qui
pourra pas volé 10 millions $ ce n'est
plus à la vie désormais
je n'ai pas beaucoup de temps il n'a que
douze heures vous pensez qu'il dit la
vérité
je ne crois pas pour blé 10 millions de
dollars alerte incendie s'est déclenché
à la parie cependant je veux qu'on le
coin
ton père m'a abandonnée
je vais faire payer pour ce qu'il nous a
fait à tous les deux
je vais te sortir de large
le temps est écoulé